there are many ways you can think about
these talks I've two talks back-to-back
and what one is is really very specific
and one is fairly general but you can
think about them as being one is about
the front of the eye and the other is
about the back of the eye right so
things are very specialized in this
world and and a lot of Surgeons for
example would work on the front of the
eye and these things like cataract and
LASIK and whatnot and some work on the
back of the eye and take care of things
like macular degeneration and the abetik
retinopathy and alike so you're in luck
because I actually do both and sometimes
I think maybe I'll get arrested for
doing both but it gives you a good
perspective and then we'll talk about
this so so this first talk is about the
reduction of astigmatism I'm gonna go
very quickly through what we mean by
astigmatism and some historical notes
this is some credits here and basically
Thomas Young the famous Thomas Young the
physicist towards the very beginning of
the 19th century discovered astigmatism
by just looking at a little pen pushing
it back and forth turning it around and
seeing that the picture was blurry in in
one plane but if he pushed it a little
bit to a different plane it would become
clearer and if he turned his pan that I
became blurry again and he had to go to
a different plane to get it clear right
so so that was the first view of
stigmatised now he is also gonna come to
this in just the second year here he is
so he has worked he's done a lot of work
on on deciphering the Rosetta Stone and
hieroglyphics and that was finally
clinched by champu Liang right so I
think there's kind of a very interesting
in our analogy because he also started
with a stigmatism and for
you know two centuries essentially we
still don't have a perfect way of
eliminating and stigmatised now a
stigmatise is very annoying because if
you're near-sighted if you're just
nearsighted then there's a place where
you can see things right you have to
bring things close and then you see them
right and if you're maybe not in your
sighted that's sort of a little
farsighted and reasonably young and you
can see far so there's a place where you
can actually have some but if you have a
stigmatism there's no no near no far or
nothing everything's blurry all the time
at all plane in all planes right so so
it's particularly annoying okay so well
I'm going to be talking about is going
to be related to the correction mainly
about the correction of stigmatism the
time of cataract surgery so here are a
couple of examples of cataracts once you
get a fairly advanced cataract you can't
see much and the evolution of cataract
surgery is very interesting in its own
right and we have come to a point where
we can very cleanly very safely remove
these cataracts but also reduce any kind
of nearsightedness farsightedness etc
and very recently reduced a lot of the
astigmatism at the same time that we are
removing this cataract and giving this
patient not only better vision than they
had just before their cataract but maybe
a better vision I've had into all of
their whole life okay so here are just
some numbers the ways so most people
will have a little bit of a stigmatism
have one by the time you have have two
one that's a lot of astigmatism you have
to get it corrected and the glasses will
correct up to a resolution of 1/4
diopter and people present for cataract
surgery almost half of them can benefit
from something some intervention to to
get this corrected
so other than glasses contact lenses you
can also do an excimer laser something
like LASIK but that's a different
procedure
more expense more risk etc then there
are relaxing incisions which are sort of
by hand you know cutting with a little
knife the cornea or the limbus which is
the edge of the cornea or you can do it
with a femtosecond laser that's a much
more recent development and these are
done in the cornea and I'm going to show
you some numbers and finally you can do
intraocular lenses so now very recently
we have these specialty lenses that are
not spherical lenses the lenses
themselves have a stigmatism but they
have just the right amount of stigmatism
hopefully to cancel the pigment is that
you have now these lenses for obvious
practical reasons cannot be manufactured
by like custom manufactured even though
we have like 3d printers and all of that
for now they're produced that I produced
in sort of steps so that's one of the
limitations and if you do one of these
lenses you can get close but you can
still be left with quite a bit of
astigmatism alright so this talk is
going to show a technique which is a
novel technique and that was developed
that I developed and that I used
Mathematica to kind of implement in a
very quantitative and and an exact way
to reduce the stigmatism to zero so as
the abstract says you know throughout
history we've been trying to reduce
reduce elusive stigmatised but typically
it's done with one technique and it
brings you maybe close maybe not that
close with different variability but but
you still have something remaining but
you are converging to 0 and hopefully
this takes us essentially to zero ok so
here it is this is how you can represent
it and and the graph shows the the color
graph shows in the cornea with the
orange being is steeper
or curvature direction or meridian and
the green shows a flatter left less
steepness meridian and that's what what
it means for the cornea to have
astigmatism on the other side you have
some examples of how somebody's put
these lenses would be computed and and
and positioned and that's from one of
the manufacturers of the lens
okay so these are some of the companies
that make these special lenses in the
United States we have three such
companies outcome came early earlier
there was a different company that
actually came even earlier than alcohol
but they are no longer in the business
of manufacturing these lenses they have
some issues so icon is around 2005 and
for quite a long time it wasn't that
popular or as successful there's some
issues with the rotation and so on and
then you have Abbott which makes the
techniques and Bausch and Lomb and these
are fairly recent have the approvals a
couple of years all right
now here's one of the problems that we
have that each company does not want to
tell you about the other companies
products right that makes the Flex Coke
and Pepsi type thing right so so if you
want to get your optimal lens then you
go to one of these and you'll see what
you can get and I say well could I do
better with another lens and then what
you have to do while you go start over
at the other companies site and you say
well how about the third company and you
go and you try again now if you don't
live in the United States or if you live
in some other countries now you have
many more companies that have approval
on their lenses okay so it's it's more
expensive to get these these approved in
the United States so not all companies
so you have a whole bunch of these and
most of them do the same thing just to
give you an example these are the ones
that are approved in the United States
and I don't think he gave me a late
but that's life I can try to do this
yeah so the amount of astigmatism
corrected at the IRL plane which is the
intraocular lens plane is here and the
one at the corneal plane is is is there
so there is a correspondence thank you
right right yeah here we go yeah yeah
thank you so so this number here
correspond to the amount of the
stigmatised you can correct from one
point five to six measured where the
lens is but you don't care about this
because your stigmatism that you see
with is that the cornea now there is a
conversion factor and for this company
and many other companies they use a
constant conversion factor which is not
really accurate so this is a sideshow
this is work we've done in the past
couple of years and it shows what the
conversion factor should be so we have
done some work including with
Mathematica and with assistance from
Stephan LeBlanc to sitting here in in
getting this kind of exact conversion
which of course contributes a lot now
these are really relaxing decisions the
solute cuts you're making the eye and
this is what they correct so that's an
example of a correct have 0.75 1 5 3 so
you can see it's also quantized so it's
like little jumps so because it's little
jumps if you happen to have like 1.9
astigmatism
you have a lens that we correct u21 5
you have a stigmatism correctional
corrector 1:5 right so you're going to
be left with 0.4 in both cases and
that's quite a bit of a stigmatism
and of course you have a little bit of
uncertainty if you get a couple of like
point two or point three of uncertainty
from the surgery on this on top of this
then you're still not not clean and nice
alright so what can we do so we can
combine them ok I'm not gonna have a lot
of time to go through the technique for
the combination
but I do want to say that we can focus
on this example here with this example
is the same one that at 1.9 a segment is
to be corrected ok now what I can do is
to put the toric lens at this angle and
to put a relaxing incision at that angle
and that can be computed exactly all
right
so here is sort of the Mathematica or
the geometric output and the core of the
talk is here all right so it's very
abstract it's not labeled it's secret it
is filed in a pattern that hasn't
published yet or in a patent filing that
hasn't published yet and the point is
this each one of these circles
represents the the correction of one of
the toric lenses ok
so let's say I think this is the one
this is maybe the one point five so if
you do 1.5 you can do this now your
stigmatism is this blue dot so if you do
it 1.5 you are going to be short by 0.4
okay now the dotted circles represent
the the relaxing incisions and so if you
do just a relaxing incision then again
you're going to be missing your your
little dot bye-bye
you know a certain a certain amount like
if you're doing a 1.5 we're gonna be so
the point is that the circles intersect
okay so any intersection of this other
circles gives you a perfect correction
of astigmatism it gets you to zero right
and this has to do with the way that
segment is combined so the beauty here
is first of all I get multiple solutions
so not only do I have one way of
reducing spend but I have multiple ways
of introducing astigmatism and if you
invert the logic a little bit and you
say you know what I want I'm going to
have just one lens and one relaxing
incision I don't want to produce any
more lenses I don't want to deal with
any complicated ways of cutting the eye
and going to it in only one way then if
you do that then by by positioning your
your your incisions properly and your
lenses properly you can actually correct
a lot of different values of the
astigmatism okay so you can get the
whole spectrum so you you you kind of
developed like a basis from which you
construct this high dimensional space
and this is an example of how this has
been done okay so it's particular case
1.9 is corrected in this way what are
the advantages you can definitely
targets your astigmatism you minimize
the rotation of the intraocular lens
remember I told you company went out of
business completely the reason it went
out of the company is not out of
business but they don't make this lenses
anymore the reason it started with their
lenses rotating if it rotates it doesn't
give it a correct correction anymore so
you can minimize this by combining with
one of this relaxing incision it avoids
the main cataract incision here's your
main cataract incision if you were to
only do the cut it would overlap your
cataract incision that's not good
surgical alright you have a much reduced
basis or require darrell's simplifies
the need for surgical tools simpler
surgery with better outcomes okay so we
have a system we have developed this is
prior to this particular addition of
this technique that provides for all of
these lenses it's it's and the
calculator it has a core calculator it
has a front end and a lens data base and
each one of these is a is universal in
the sense that is explained here so we
have for example the manufacturers we
have all of the manufacture included so
you don't have to jump from side to side
to side to side to side to side and
spend two hours or god knows how much
time to finally find all of them are
listed and all of them are matched so
it's a little bit like your Travelocity
of intraocular lenses for cataract
surgery okay this is an example of the
interface that's very recent actually
and and it's it's it's very very rich
and very flexible okay so putting it all
together that calculation includes the
spherical computation for all IRL
intraocular lens manufacturers you have
multiple formers with optimization you
include the correct conversion from lens
plane to cornea okay which which most
companies do not do these are some of my
collaborators Stephan is here David and
Doug
we have intellectual property filed
relating to the xenos zero okay for the
combination and we plan to integrate
this new zero target method into the
calculator I showed you by the end of
the year so thank you very much I'll
take questions
[Applause]